this video is brought to you by Paradox
Interactive what's up guys
Jared again there are few filmmakers who
inspire as much adoration as Christopher
Nolan from mind-bending thrillers to
superhero adventures to world war ii
epics no one has made solid films in
many genres but there's one Nolan movie
that's divided the wisecrack crew some
proclaim it a masterpiece while others
just roll their eyes I'm talking about
his big space opus interstellar there
was so much hype surrounding
interstellar release Nolan had already
been called the new Stanley Kubrick and
this film was supposed to cement this
comparison with no one's very own 2001 a
Space Odyssey yet reactions were mixed
people praised the ambition and the
visuals of the film while taking issues
with some of the more emotional moments
while the Dark Knight inception and the
prestige have been discussed studied and
deemed irrefutable smart it seems the
jury's still out on interstellar but
don't worry we're here to finally put
that question to rest so welcome to this
wisecrack edition on interstellar deep
or dumb and yeah obviously spoilers
ahead but before we get into that I want
to give a shout out to this video
sponsor surviving Mars and their newest
expansion green planet similar to
interstellar surviving Mars focuses on
what it might be like to start a colony
on a new planet this survival strategy
game explores the challenges that will
come with moving to a new planet the
newest expansion focuses on terraforming
an entire planet to be livable for
humans so stick around to the end of the
video to hear more about the game or
check it out yourself by clicking the
link in the description and now back to
the show okay first a quick recap in the
not-too-distant future a global blight
has rendered most of Earth's land
useless humanity's only hope is ex-pilot
Cooper and his ten-year-old daughter
Murph who mysteriously received
coordinates from a ghostly presence that
leads them to a secret NASA headquarters
led by coops former mentor dr. John
brand recently an alien entity opened up
a wormhole that may lead to a new
habitable planet dr. brand is developing
a gravitational equation to save
humanity by relocating everyone to
another planet but if that doesn't work
plan B is to leave
Manatee behind and populate a new planet
with frozen embryos with the embryos in
tow coop reluctantly sets out to the
wormhole leaving his daughter and son
behind coop and the crew including dr.
brands daughter Amelia reached one of
the potential planets but an error in
their plan costs them 23 years due to
relativity Murph now grown-up discovers
that dr. brand was lying his equation
that would save the people of Earth was
a sham the only hope for Humanity lies
in the embryos on board coops ship yet
Murph refuses to give up and continues
to search for an answer
coop eventually sacrifices himself so
that Amelia can go on with the human
embryos and falls into the black hole
but he's saved by the quote aliens who
have made him a cozy little tesseract
which he can use to communicate with
Murph turns out these aliens are into
aliens their future humans Murph
realizes the ghostly presence from her
childhood was actually her father all
along and she decodes a new message from
him to complete brands equation and save
humanity off the dying earth coop wakes
up on a space station populated with
Earth's inhabitants where he finally
reunites with his daughter now well over
90
she tells coop that his mission isn't
over he needs to go find Amelia and a
new planet for Humanity the end now
before we can determine if interstellar
is deep or dumb we first have to
understand what Nolan was trying to
achieve
everyone always makes the 2001
comparisons and at first glance this may
seem apt both films have an alien
artifact space exploration a robot a
second act dominated by a crew member
going loco and a phantasmagoria third
act but these are only aesthetic
similarities underneath it all the films
are quite different
whereas Kubrick's film is meant to give
us deliberately opaque answers to the
unknown interstellar does the opposite
it seeks to embolden us to inspire us to
make the unknown knowable and
transparent now I know what you're
thinking
what does making the unknown knowable
even mean well let's look at three ways
he tries to communicate this message
part 1 interstellar setting and
structure interstellar is set on an
earth on the brink of collapse the
amount of arable land dwindles by the
day all science points to humanity
in one generation tops even worse
everyone has given up on any long-term
solution resigned to just maintain life
for as long as possible before their
inevitable doom Cooper a former NASA
pilot does exactly this
he forego his dreams of Aero exploration
to tend to his farm and family in this
new world hope is suppressed space
travel was treated not just as a
wasteful impracticality but an outright
lie in order to stifle any ambitions
outside the immediate issues facing
humanity textbooks have been rewritten
to suggest that the lunar landing was a
hoax
NASA too has been dismantled and
disgraced and if we don't want a repeat
of the excess and wastefulness of the
20th century then we need to teach our
kids about this planet not tales of
leaving it but interstellar argues
against this to not get bogged down in
the existential dread but to fight
against the dying of the light
dr. brand constantly repeats Dylan
Thomas's poem do not go gentle into that
good night do not go gentle into that
good night old age should burn and rave
at close of day
rage rage against the dying of the light
and it reflects the film's primary ethos
the pioneer spirit American rhetoric
often assumes this quintessential belief
that growth and survival comes through
exploration this ethos led to the
country's expansion into the West and
its exploration into space brand uses
Thomas's poem to incentivize Cooper and
his NASA engineers to leave their
families and look to the Stars for a
solution to humanity's crisis dr. brand
uses the lie of his gravitational
equation to give humanity hope for a
better world if he told the truth coop
wouldn't leave his family and pilot the
spaceship the human race would
inevitably die out it's only through the
lie that bran keeps the pioneer spirit
intact Cooper to constantly extols the
pioneer ethos I thought we forgot Nui
hardhome explorers pioneers not
caretakers no he used to look up in the
sky and wonder and I place my stars look
no further than how he defines Murphy's
Law typically Murphy's Law is stated as
the adage anything that can go wrong
will go wrong a fairly pessimistic and
resigned outlook this falls in line with
most of humanity's thinking in the film
that the planet is doomed and we should
just use what little time is left to
feed our own before oblivion comes but
coop favors a less traditional
definition per coupe Murphy's Law
instead means a half and what it means
is it whatever can happen will had this
recontextualization favors the pioneer
ethos to explore outwards discover
things and expand the definition of what
can happen to explorers yet the plot of
interstellar sometimes undercuts this
ethos Cooper's journey into the unknown
has already been pre-planned he's just a
pawn in future humanity's grand circular
scheme if these fifth dimensional aliens
ie future us are guiding Cooper the
entire time it makes the whole human
ingenuity thing a whole lot less
convincing
I mean is Cooper really saving mankind
through the pioneer ethos or has he been
given all the answers by a metaphysical
helping hand
no one also highlights the importance of
the pioneer ethos through the film
structure interstellar in some ways
resembles Joseph Conrad's seminal
novella heart of darkness which is all
about journeying into the unknown in
heart of darkness Marlow a sea captain
sails down the Congo River yearning to
fill in the blank spaces on his map
similarly in interstellar Cooper leads
an expedition into the blank reaches of
space driven by a need to explore the
unknown
Doyle even refers to the black hole
Cooper and his team are traveling to as
as Marlow delves deeper into the heart
of darkness he comes face to face with
the dark side of man this is personified
by Colonel Kurtz who preceded Marlow
into the jungle hoping to civilize the
indigenous populations in regular
society Kurtz is praised as a remarkable
man with a generous mind whose goodness
shown in every act yet by the time
Marlow reaches Kurtz the jungle has
corrupted him whole Kurtz no longer has
any interest in civilizing the people he
just wants to exterminate all the brutes
in interstellar dr. Mann too is
described as the best of us as a
remarkable man he once said the doctor
man just like Kurtz man preceded Cooper
into space and by the time Cooper
reaches him man has been corrupted by
his time alone on the newfound planet
both Kurtz and man are consumed by their
own selfish desires Kurtz forces the
natives to worship Him proclaiming
everything in the jungle his own you
should have heard him say my ivory my
intended my ivory my station my River my
everything belonged to him and man
selfishly lies about the habitable
prospects of his planet just so others
will come to save him
even egotistically refers to the planet
as his own truth is
I never really considered the
possibility that my planet wasn't the
one just as heart of darkness comments
on the innate selfishness of mankind
Noland uses man to cynically do the same
I mean the character's name is man also
one could draw a parallel between dr.
brands necessary lie about the gravity
equation with Marlo's lie - Kurtz's
intended at the novellas end falsely
telling her that Kurtz's last words were
her name but using heart of darkness to
celebrate humanity's pioneer ethos is a
little awkward
Conrad presented a much more nuanced
look at exploration the idea to explore
may be pure but often went hand in hand
with European imperialism the conquest
of the earth which mostly means the
taking it away from those who have a
different complexion or slightly flatter
noses than ourselves is not a pretty
thing when you look into it too much
what redeems it is the idea only yet
furred Nolan exploration specifically
the space variety is an unabashedly pure
and worthwhile pursuit now while we
wouldn't go as far as to say the movie
is dumb for alluding to Conrad it's just
not the most precise reference to make
same with the whole predestination thing
not the most graceful way to celebrate
humanity's will to go beyond but
regardless for setting and structure
we're gonna go with a soft deep part to
interstellar religious imagery it may
sound odd for a film that purports to a
noble man's search for certainty deals
in religious imagery yet interstellar is
loaded with religious symbolism which to
be fair many have commented on in the
past there's an omniscient godlike being
who creates a wormhole and guides
everything originally 12 astronauts are
sent to explore this wormhole just as
Jesus sent out 12 disciples in his name
and Cooper becomes to represent the Holy
Trinity first as the Sun when Cooper
like Jesus sacrifices himself to save
humanity and like Jesus
Cooper's miraculously resurrected and
comes back to civilization
only to immediately leave once again he
even spends time wandering in the
wilderness albeit on an uninhabitable
planet instead of the desert when Cooper
enters the godlike beings tesseract he
becomes the Holy Spirit ie the ghost
guiding Murphy and himself in the past
later cooper becomes the father reaching
out and touching Amelia when they first
enter the wormhole a la Michelangelo's
the Creation of Adam there are even two
Noah's arks one the spaceship holding
the embryos that Cooper pilots for a
majority of the run time and the other
in the film's coda the spaceship
transporting earth survivors through the
cosmos these religious images aren't
about crafting anything mystical though
in fact the opposite is true
interstellar incorporates these
religious elements into an explainable
framework the godlike omniscient beings
guiding everything is just Humanity in
the future the ghost that gives them
coordinates it's just coop in the
tesseract Cooper's seemingly never aging
and rising from the dead Einstein's
relativity in practice miracles can
happen but not through prayer instead
miracles like saving humanity from
extinction
come through science the pioneer spirit
and belief in the imagination Hans
Zimmer's score which utilizes religious
organs highlights this point per Noland
I wanted Zimmer to use the church organ
I also made the case very strongly for
some feeling of religiosity to it even
though the film isn't religious but that
the organ the architecture cathedrals
and all the rest they represent
mankind's attempt to portray the
mystical or the metaphysical what's
beyond us beyond the realm of the
everyday yet again no one speaks to the
importance of journeying into the
unknown because what might seem beyond
us even the metaphysical can possibly be
understood and help us in the face of
insurmountable odds so for this novel
treatment of religious imagery we're
also going to say deep part three
interstellar science of love no one
consulted for years with American
theoretical physicist and Nobel laureate
Gabe Thorne
there's even an entire book that
explains these scientific concepts
behind the film's cosmological ideas
science is a huge part of interstellar
the be plot centers around Murph
attempting to solve a seemingly
impossible gravitational equation but in
order to figure it out she can't just
blindly accept what dr. brand thinks
that the equation is impossible yet
again no one stresses the importance of
pursuing the unknown not just in the
cosmos but in science at
self instead of dismissing what might
seem unknowable as nonsense
humanity must confront these problems
with due diligence and try to
incorporate these ideas into the
scientific method I'm just tell me that
you're afraid if someone goes record the
facts on the way and present your
conclusions this necessity of
incorporating uncertainty into
frameworks that seek to solidify
certainty is developed in a really
clever subplot involving tars in which
it's revealed that tarses optimal
honesty setting is only at 90 percent
hey tars what's your honesty parameter
ninety percent ninety percent
nor the safest form of communication
with emotional beings while we might
think of emotion as being counter to
rational thinking tars is 10 percent
dishonesty calculus suggests that
emotion can be incorporated into a model
seeking absolute certainty and since
we're on the topic of emotion let's talk
about love yes this is where things get
a little dicey and where most claims of
dumbness have been leveled at the film
interstellar takes a big emotional swing
for the fences arguing that just like
traditional science emotions a la love
can also be quantified and known you all
know the scene it has to mean something
love people who have died where's the
social utility in that maybe it means
something more something we can't yet
understand maybe it's some evidence some
artifact of a higher dimension that we
can't consciously perceive I'm drawn
across the universe to someone I haven't
seen in a decade who
I know he's probably dead love is the
one thing we're capable of perceiving
that transcends dimensions of time and
space maybe we should trust that even if
we can't understand it yet in the film
backs up this monologue in the end
Amelia's right about which planet is
habitable later in the tesseract
Cooper's able to figure out how to
communicate with Murph through his love
for her no one seems to be arguing the
same as before just because love seems
undefinable doesn't mean we should
dismiss it as such instead we should you
know the drill
attempt to understand this unknown and
use it for our betterment and yet the
film's actual definition of love feels
vague at best
unlike the scientific and religious
connotations which are given specific
answers interstellar manifestation of
love boils down altima ly to some sort
of gut instinct coupe claims that it's
through love that future humanity guided
him to just the right time and place in
the tesseract so that he could
communicate with Murph though even that
is a bit vague but to be fair how can
you define emotions in anything but the
vaguest of terms it's a problem that
interstellar can't quite master
so yeah in a movie all about journeying
into the unknown and using science and
reason to solve humanity's crises it
does feel a little odd to fall back on a
vague appeal to love as the grand
solution but perhaps interstellar is
trying to suggest that love like gravity
is an observable force of attraction
just as two masses attract each other
through gravity two people are attracted
to each other through love and if that
is observable maybe it's not all
mystical mumbo-jumbo but even if you buy
that the film only seems to uphold
certain kinds of love favoring Coop's
love for his daughter while ignoring his
son the film celebrates love for someone
who's a pioneer like Murphy but then
dismisses the love for someone of the
land like Tom in interstellar zwerling
wrong with the feet in the sand earth
philosophy
so he gets left behind in the literal
dust I mean when cooper wakes up in the
future he doesn't even ask about what
happened to his son or
he's even alive that's cold and maybe
even a little dumb so what to make of
interstellar is a deep is it dumb yes
there are some awkward contradictions
and haziness around the whole love thing
but perhaps that's inevitable when
you're making a film that affirms and
celebrates our most essential human
characteristics after all no one isn't a
scientist his job isn't to write a proof
on how to quantify love his job is to
dramatize it to make us feel and just as
Cooper's message of love transcends time
and space to Murph the image of a 2013
Matthew McConaughey crying on a
soundstage in Burbank transcends time
and space and makes 2019 me all
misty-eyed in my crappy apartment so if
the film inspires you if it makes you
excited about the cosmos about
humanity's ability to use its grit and
creativity to thrust ourselves into the
future then the movie is deep because
that's the message of the film and if
this whole soap boxy speech came off as
cheesy and you didn't care well then the
movie is dumb anything that can happen
will happen after all but what do you
guys think did Doland trip over his own
ambition or is interstellar another
masterpiece thanks to all our patrons
who support the channel and our podcasts
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
as always thanks for watching guys but
before you go I want to give another
shout out to surviving Mars as a new
expansion Green Planet I recently played
the game and had a lot of fun building
my colony and terraforming Mars from
setting up your supply chains to hand
picking your colonists there are so many
things you can do to make your colony
thrive making the wrong move can be
costly but that's the thrilling thing
that sets this strategy game apart
surviving Mars is available on PC Xbox
one and ps4 and right now the base game
is available to play for free on Steam
so get started building your own colony
today by clicking the link in the
description thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]